que se ha visto hoy en el parlamento y
que pasó a estar ahora con respecto al
nuevo monarca
qué tal rodrigo buenas tardes bueno se
ha visto el primer acercamiento oficial
político de los parlamentarios como
usted mencionó ya de alguna manera con
la propia reina tenía vinculada ese
reconocimiento con sus sucesores con su
heredero y pues en realidad pues es el
componente político no es muy importante
que de alguna forma tenga ya este está
este acercamiento en una época difícil
rodrigo una época complicada para reino
unido porque desde que salió de la unión
europea en el 2016 es el éxito 2021
oficialice ha reunido a que hay una
crisis profunda sigue una de las
preocupaciones aparte de lo que usted
indica la crisis económica es el papel
que tenga el nuevo rey respecto al poder
legislativo the gardian destapó en 2015
que entre 2004 y 2005 carlos habría
presionado al gobierno de tony blair en
aspectos políticos qué papel otorga la
constitución al monarca británico
respecto al parlamento y qué principales
retos se enfrentará ahora carlos tercero
bueno es la equidistancia es decir
distante del poder de las decisiones de
los dogmas de las ideologías y de los
partidos el propio nuevo rey hace un par
de años en una entrevista
dijo textualmente sería idiota yo si
siquiera mostrando algunas de las de las
frases que he mencionado a lo largo pues
de esta época
y aquí cierro comillas creo que de
alguna manera pues se tendrá
precisamente que adaptarse a su nuevo
papel no es política es un jefe de
estado y esa es la ventaja de las
monarquías tener un jefe de estado
dejando los partidos políticos si otra
de las imágenes que hemos visto este
sábado es la de william y harry los
hijos del rey de nuevo juntos tras la
polémica salida de la casa real de harry
sin la figura de la reina isabel
presente se podría haber un acercamiento
de harry respecto a su familia
bueno yo lo dudo creo que lo está
haciendo por protocolo ahora quizás para
apoyar a su padre a su hermano también
sin lugar a dudas lo que lo que se
desencadenó cuando él renuncia a todo lo
que es el legado monárquico pues se
genera un terremoto no parecido al de
nacimiento similar al de su madre diana
el 97 pero sí recordó mucho ese fantasma
es decir el menciona la palabra
a que hay racismo dentro de la monarquía
entonces creo que en ese sentido no va a
cambiar mucho el papel de su hermano
william también de su padre con respecto
a otra de las preocupaciones
posibles de es adhesiones posibles
salidas de la commonwealth de algunos
países que papel podrían jugar qué retos
se enfrentan también en este punto si es
2021 el año 22 y ahora las
complicaciones por ejemplo en jamaica
dicen que no van a reconocer lo de as lo
decían antes antes de que muriera
isabel ellos decían en jamaica que no
reconocerían una vez que muriera la
reina al nuevo rey en ese sentido la
tormenta económica que tiene enfrente el
reino unido y el mundo o el tema de la
guerra pues se convierte a la monarquía
en un a en un escenario difícil de
controlar y por lo tanto se tiene que
adaptar los jóvenes los milenios y
acoger en la monarquía y es precisamente
lo que tendría que hacer a un nuevo rey
como acercarse es la gran pregunta